was haben scharfe knappen bauten blonde
perücken roboter ampeln und echter gouda
miteinander zu tun
all das ist typisch afrikas genau
klein oder groß blond oder weiß
hier trägt jeder locken
alle diese jungen leute hier bekommen
heute ihre zulassung als anwalt vor
gericht aber warum tragen sie heute noch
diese perücken jetzt als anwalt ist es
teil der tradition
das ist schon in ordnung ich bin stolz
drauf
wir haben heute einige gesagt wie
lächerlich wie aussehen und wir wären
besser ohne dran doch heute trägt auch
james an januar seine perücke mit stolz
vier stunden vorher der 26 jährige macht
sich fertig für seinen großen tag sein
studium hat er erfolgreich beendet ich
wollte schon immer anwalt werden
heute ist es soweit es bedeutet mir sehr
viel
und dafür sind robe und perücke pflicht
james hat sich die sachen ausgeliehen
rund 34 euro hat er umgerechnet bezahlt
die standes garderobe zu kaufen hätte
zehnmal mehr gekostet
wie findest du es
ich sehe gut aus aber ich bin kein
großer fan der perücke ist erinnert mich
an die kolonialzeit
die ist in kenia aber seit 65 jahren
beendet oder etwa nicht
die perücke jedenfalls hat überlebt
verantwortlich dafür ist die
gesellschaft der kenianischen anwälte
sie geben vor wer anwalt werden will
muss locken tragen bis es gibt so viele
dinge die koloniales erbe sind die aber
an sich nicht falsch sind und das gilt
auch für die roben und die perücken und
schließlich komme das rechtssystem auch
aus dieser zeit vorgeschrieben ist der
koloniale kopfschmuck aber nur an diesem
tag danach entscheidet jeder selbst
zu koloniale oder nicht das wird in
kenia immer wieder diskutiert bislang
ohne folgen für die 273 neun anwälte
wird die perücke aber schnell zur
nebensache
endlich am ziel alle sind einfach nur
stolz ich bin so glücklich danke mein
sohn und manch einer oder eine box dann
doch rasch für die eigene kenianische
tradition
kinshasa hauptstadt der demokratischen
republik kongo
eine dieser millionen metropolen afrikas
mit vielen vielen verkehrsteilnehmern
würden sie sich in diesem verkehrschaos
einem roboter anvertrauen
genau das tun die menschen in kinshasa
mitten auf vielen gruseligen kreuzungen
stehen metallene riesen und zeigen ganz
gemächlich rot und grün an der rott kopf
eine mischung aus roboter und kopf den
englischen wort für polizist
robocop machen gute arbeit in unserem
land das ist etwas sehr modern
eigentlich hilft es aber im moment bin
im teer sich nicht ordentlich passiert
auch den besten roboter mal heute nur
einarmig diese hinterhofwerkstatt
entstehen die modernen
verkehrspolizisten
sie riskieren sie hat sie erfunden und
kann uns sicher die frage beantworten
was robert cops im verkehr so
einzigartig macht die roboter machen
täglich 3600 bewegungen normale ampeln
stehen einfach nur um diese bewegungen
sorgen dafür dass man sich am
straßenverkehr erfreuen kann diese auf
und ab bewegungen sind amüsant der
hobbykoch ist wie ein menschliches wesen
aber warum nimmt man nicht gleich
menschen die bewegen sich doch auch der
robocop regelt den verkehr auch bei
regen und nachts er ist immer da ist ja
eine maschine
aber ganz alleine kommen die
menschlichen maschinenwesen dann doch
nicht klar
verkehrspolizisten passen auf die
roboter auf und vor allem darauf dass
die autofahrer ihnen auch gehorchen das
versteht nicht jeder
also entweder das eine oder das andere
so wird geld zum fenster rausgeworfen
tiere scirocco sie geht es noch um etwas
anderes
im 21 jahrhundert muss afrika aufwachen
und anfangen seine intelligenz zu
verkaufen und fertige produkte das
sollte unser schlachtross sein
die erfinderinnen wünscht sich eine
ganze robocop truppe für amüsanten
straßenverkehr auf der ganzen welt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich bin hier nicht etwa mit einer
politischen demonstration
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und zwar im westen kenias der sarg eines
verstorbenen wird zur grabstätte
geleitet mit dabei sind familie freunde
und professionelle bezahlte trauergäste
sie geben ihr bestes
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich kann gar nicht mehr zählen um wie
viele leute ich schon geweint habe
bereits früh am morgen bereiten sich die
angeheuerten trauergäste vor
mit selbst gebranntem schnaps nur so
kommen sie in die richtige stimmung die
sie für den heutigen auftrag brauchen
richtig los geht es dann vor der
leichenhalle von kisumu apropos stimmung
trillerpfeifen scheinen ein muss zu sein
wenn man jemanden zu grabe trägt jeden
freitag versammeln sich zahllose
menschen an der leichenhalle um sich von
verstorbenen zu verabschieden
uns fällt es dabei zunächst schwer die
bezahlten von den echten trauernden zu
unterscheiden
[Musik]
aber diese gruppe besteht eindeutig aus
profis sie hoffen dass jemand sie für
geld engagiert aber warum macht man das
eigentlich also man heuer die an damit
die hinterbliebenen die sich einsam
fühlen aufgemuntert werden das ist gut
so wenn man genug geld hat holt man
professionelle trauergäste weil das zu
unserer kultur gehört umgerechnet bis zu
200 euro bekommt eine gruppe profi
trauernder für eine beerdigung viel geld
in einer sonst sehr armen gegend wenn
jemand im krankenhaus liegt und zu etwa
50 euro für medizin braucht dann gib dir
keiner das geld aber wenn derjenige der
tod ist dann zahlen alle gerne das
zehnfache gegeben vielmehr für tote aus
als für die lebenden
je aufwendiger die beerdigung also desto
mehr ehre post für die professionellen
trauergäste machen stimmung bis der
verstorbene unter der erde ist meist auf
dem familiengrundstück bis dahin haben
sie sich stundenlang verausgabt trauern
gegen bezahlung dabei wird man am ende
todmüde
[Musik]
ganz großes kino heute bei der hay
videoshow ein internationaler knaller
nach dem anderen
wir erwarten leute von überall her aus
nairobi aus mombasa wird sich fast nach
oscar-verleihung an richtige maiskolben
statt popcorn das gibt es vor diesem
kino hier in bonn sowie in der mitte
kenias und alle warten schon ganz
gespannt auf den kino dj aber was ist
das die kinder kennen ihn alle und die
cineasten zahlen umgerechnet 20 cent für
eine vorstellung mit ihnen ich schaue
mir keinen fehler ohne dj afro an kino
interessiert mich nur wegen ihm
und dann kommt er dj afro ein superstar
in kenias filmszene seien zur dvd beamer
mischpult und viel fantasie
[Musik]
ich bin künstler und als künstler muss
man kreativ sein
ich erfinde meine eigenen späße und
witze und manchmal auch eine eigene
geschichte um den film interessanter zu
machen
sein rezept ton weg von einem beliebigen
blockbuster und los geht's also der hier
sehr viel alkohol das sieht man sofort
doch doch liebe zuschauer genauso ist
das kirchgänger erkennt man genauso die
haben immer vaseline im gesicht damit
sie göttlich strahlen aber zurück zur
geschichte also im kino wird es immer
wärmer kino djs gibt es in china schon
seit jahrzehnten
englisch ist zwar eine der zwei
amtssprachen wird aber nicht überall
fließend gesprochen
deshalb kommt der kino dj ins spiel er
übersetzt und interpretiert auf
kisuaheli oder kikuyu aber nicht jeder
ist so berühmt wie dj afro nach
eineinhalb stunden ist die vorstellung
vorbei und alle erschöpft
auch die nicht mehr reingepasst haben
bekommen ihr idol nun noch zu gesicht
anfangs haben die leute gesagt dieser
typ versaut filme
sie haben mich nicht ernst genommen aber
ich habe mit leidenschaft weitergemacht
nichts konnte mich davon abhalten
und so ist der kino dj auch ein
hoffnungsträger einmal berühmt sein wie
er
das wäre ein schönes happy end
[Musik]
hohe fassaden grauer beton hier können
viele menschen auf kleinem raum wohnen
das erinnert mich doch an etwas aber was
macht dann die palme da solche gebäude
kenne ich eigentlich nur aus deutschland
wie kommen plattenbauten nach sansibar
diese hier stehen mitten in sansibar
stone town in einem der häuser und fahre
die mit er ist fremdenführer immer
nachmittags setzt er sich vor das haus
und verteilt selbstgekochtes porridge
mit vanille und chili drin kostenlos
damit eher entspannt mit jedem plaudern
kann der vorbei schaut echt lecker farid
bringt mich aufs dach damit ich die
ganze siedlung sehen kann gibt es denn
wirklich eine verbindung nach
deutschland
präsident sansibar ist viel gereist und
er verehrte die deutschen gebäude und
deren design
es bedeutet dass wir eine verbindung
nach deutschland haben er war sehr stolz
solche gebäude zu bauen
finanziert hat sansibar die wohnungen in
den siebzigern selbst erklärt er mir
farid nachbar safe massa zeigte seine
wohnung seine mutter ist damals hier
eingezogen
zum ersten mal fließend wasser direkt im
haus und eine keramik toilette aber
freiwillig kam sie nicht unser haus hier
wurde zerstört und meine mutter wusste
nicht was sie tun sollte doch dann haben
sie ihr diese wohnung gegeben ohne dass
sie zahlen musste als kompensation dann
war sie sehr zufrieden
die wohnung hat sie vererbt und er wird
es genauso machen denn die betonbauten
sind viel beliebter als die alten häuser
in der nachbarschaft stabiler und es
regnet weniger rein
diese häuser hier orientieren sich also
nur am baustil der plattenbauten
es gibt aber auch häuser in stone town
die tatsächlich von deutschen gebaut
worden sind
ein paar hundert meter weiter
berlin werden diese häuser auch genannt
sie waren ein geschenk der ddr uns
damals sozialistische sansibar gebaut in
den 60er jahren von deutschen
ingenieuren saada hamas hat damals eine
wohnung hier bekommen und auch sie will
diese unbedingt in ihrer familie
weitergeben
wir mögen diese häuser auch wenn sie
lecken und kaputt sind
ich habe diese narbe hier
da ist ein stück küchendecke
heruntergefallen genau auf mich drauf
ich musste ins krankenhaus fahren und
wurde genäht aber wir wollen weiter hier
leben nur renovieren das wäre bei den
deutschen häusern dringend mal nötig
ein wochenend spaziergang mit meinem
hund cookie herrlich die eingehen gerne
gassi die anderen haben lieber nur
nachts tierische gesellschaft spät
nachmittags fahren seltsame autos durch
kenias hauptstadt nairobi
sie bringen vierbeiner zu ihrem job als
wachhunde mit einem wächter zusammen
passen sie auf grundstücke auf wenn es
dunkel wird denn nairobi also nairobi
ist für kriminalität berühmt berüchtigt
nach einer hoffentlich räuber freien
nacht kommen die hunde wieder bei ihrem
eigentlichen härchen an einer
sicherheitsfirma bevor sie sich gleich
ausruhen dürfen gibt es noch ein kleines
auf frisch training im angreifen
ein ausbilder spielt dem bösen in einem
bissfesten anzug so könnte sich ein
überfall auf das grundstück eines kunden
abspielen
die miet hunde werden darauf trainiert
einbrecher zur strecke zu bringen sie
aber nicht zu töten
in einer realen situation hätte ich
einen arm verloren die hunde beißen fest
dazu je mehr man sich wehrt wenn man
sich ergibt dass das viel sicherer
nächste trainingseinheit gehorsam ein
hund mit nicht alleine vermietet sondern
arbeitet immer mit einem wächter
zusammen
dem muss er aufs wort gehorchen wir
raten unseren kunden er einen hund als
nur einen nachtwächter zu mieten denn
menschen sind nun mal menschen der
wächter schläft mitten in der nacht ein
aber der hund ist immer wachsam wie
heißt er denn das dürfen wir aus
sicherheitsgründen nicht verraten ist
streicheln erlaubt
nicht wenn er im dienst ist nach dem
training freuen sich die live aus wenn
sie gebürstet und gewaschen werden
allein diese sicherheits firma vermietet
jede nacht 250 hunde zu etwa 650 euro
pro tier mit wächter im monat auch
nachwuchs wird gezüchtet
besonders beliebt sind rottweiler und
schäferhunde eignen sich denn alle
gleich gut zum vermieten
nach einiger zeit sieht man welcher hund
gut als wächter ist welcher gut als
drogen schnüffelt hund und welcher sich
nur gut als haustier ereignis ab ich
glaube dafür habe ich das perfekte
exemplar erwischt ist ja auch nicht
bietet
[Applaus]
sonntagmorgen in dakar senegal statt
jeder der was auf sich hält die zum
strand wirklich jeder selbst warmduscher
müssen rein in den kalten atlantik
aber was ist das wird geschrubbt ich
frag mich warum machen die senegalesen
ihre schafe im meer ist sie gegen die
parasiten oder steckt da mehr dahinter
auf jeden fall ist es eine ernste
angelegenheit hier bleibt kein schäfchen
im trockenen
wir menschen uns das auch so manche
duschen sicherer zweimal am tag also
waschen die auch unsere schafe einmal
die woche um ihnen einen ordentlichen
äußeres zu geben einmal im jahr gibt es
sogar ein schönheitswettbewerben
senegals next topmodel oder er top
chancen für die gewinnerin gibt es ein
foto und umgerechnet 3000 euro ein schaf
ist hier echt was wert das pulver geht's
an die schafswolle für den ganz
besonderen glanz schafe werden im
senegal aufgeopfert erzählt udo an die
traditionellen götter da muss das schaf
natürlich sauber sein
und noch ein grund für das bad im meer
also wenn ein schaf inside fahrzeuge
waschen wird es danach einfach besser
vielleicht kann hier deshalb nicht vom
schweigen der lämmer die rede sein
den schäfchen schwant böses pure
erleichterung bei dem wie es hinter sich
haben
[Musik]
stimmt die mögen darf nicht aber du
musst dich zwingen
zweitens dritten mal mögen sie es nicht
aber beim vierten mal wird es ihnen spaß
machen nur vor den atlantik wellen muss
man die schäfchen beschützen
dafür braucht man den richtigen griff
[Musik]
ich finde langsam gefallen daran
weißt du hier in deutschland überrascht
am sonntag eure autos für uns sind
unsere chance unsere autos
[Musik]
sie sind anders für uns ich verstehe
eine tägliche plackerei wasserholen
wäschewaschen überall in afrika machen
dass frauen hier in abidjan der
hauptstadt der elfenbeinküste ist das
allerdings anders
aber warum früh morgens sind wir an
einem flussarm am rande des kongo
nationalparks ein waschsalon in dem etwa
100 männer arbeiten und jeder hat seine
eigene waschmaschine autoreifen und
stein
[Musik]
aber es adamovich hier schon seit 27
jahren
[Musik]
sobald ich aufstehe weiß ich was ich
machen werde und muss keine andere
arbeit suchen
ich habe meine stammkunden bei denen
sammelt adamow im morgengrauen die
wäsche ein und bringt sie abends wieder
keiner seiner kollegen vertauschte
jemals kleidungsstücke sagt er zur
abwechslung sitzen mal die frauen den
ganzen tag herum
sie verkaufen den männern
aufputschmittel und dass hier was
aussieht wie etwas pappige steine ist
seite und die benutzten die männer um
die wäsche so sauber zu kriegen die ihre
kunden ist von ihnen erwarten und das
nicht ehrlich gesagt auch mehr nach
einem stein als webseite
und was ist mit der etwas na ja und
sanften methode also wenn was kaputt
geht dann nur bei die sachen vorher
schon strapaziert waren
ach so
und wie finden die frauen es dass hier
die männer schöpften das ist nur was für
kerle mit dem stein und so das ist
schwere arbeit und bei ihr zu hause wäre
wäre ich natürlich bei euch etwa nicht
[Musik]
drei vier stunden später bringt abbas
adamow die wäsche zum trocknen pro hemd
oder hose verdient er umgerechnet 10
cent genug um seine kinder in die schule
zu schicken
zu seinem angestammten trocken platz
muss adam ein ganzes stück laufen die
kunden der waschen männer von abidjan
sind übrigens fast nur männer
das könne er sich nicht erklären sagt er
was vielleicht bevorzugen frauen für
ihre kleidung doch etwas sanftere
reinigungsmethoden am nachmittag wenn
die meiste wäsche gewaschen ist dann
wird aus dem waschsalon ein schwimmbad
jungs natürlich
[Musik]
es gibt sie überall sie sind modern sie
funktionieren allein sie scheinen reine
dekoration zu sein
in nairobi fahren und gehen alle bei rot
über die straße ich auch in deutschland
wäre ich meinen führerschein jetzt
natürlich schon längst los gewesen aber
hier in kenia spielt es überhaupt keine
rolle offensichtlich ob man bei rot
fährt oder bei grün fährt und warum das
so ist möchte ich jetzt aus finden
zunächst mal frage ich die autofahrer
selbst
wir freuen uns dass auch wir verstehen
nicht warum alle bei rot fahren
ich versuche mich an die ampeln zu
halten die anderen aber nicht ich glaube
das ist kulturell bedingt naja oder ist
auch der polizei die regeln den verkehr
stimmt an jeder ampel kreuzung stehen
auch verkehrspolizisten denen die ampeln
egal zu sein scheinen und sogar
einsatzfahrzeuge fahren bei rot eine
erklärung dafür dass es müssen sie die
leute fragen die das machen
es ist den korrekt bei rot zu fahren
nein natürlich nicht
für vermeintlich gefährliches überholen
in einem stau musste ich schon mal tief
in die tasche greifen aber rote ampeln
sind im neuesten bußgeldkatalog nicht
aufgefüllt
ich frage nun profis die den kenianern
das autofahren beibringen
ich nehme fahrstunden betty mumbai ist
seit 14 jahren fahrlehrerin und weist
mich in die besonderheiten des verkehrs
in nairobi ein
warum frage ich fahren die leute bei rot
bei roth hält man an
rot bedeutet gefahr sie müssten also
anhalten und die polizei müsste die
autofahrer die sich nicht daran halten
schnappen
tun sie aber nicht obwohl es ein
lukratives geschäft wäre
mitten auf nairobis hauptverkehrsstraße
sehen wir plötzlich wandelnde ampeln go
and stop hier funktioniert es wie sie
hier
und sonst nichts
wir sind besser als ampeln
wir sagen den leuten wie sie die straße
überqueren sollen
manche menschen sind verwirrt durch die
ampeln und manche wissen gar nicht was
das soll und was die verschiedenen
farben bedeuten aber auch hier klappt es
nicht immer
[Musik]
was gehört in diese szene nicht hinein
richtig der koffer
hier in ghana wird alles auf dem kopf
getragen wirklich alles
kein menschen zieht ein koffer hinter
sich her außer mir aber ist es nicht
furchtbar unbequem sachen auf dem kopf
zu tragen
nein überhaupt nicht wenn ich dieses
tablett in der hand tragen würde dann
würde ich schnell müde werden also
traurig es auf dem kopf es ist ganz
schön schwer aber es ist auch eine art
sport okay aber warum machen sie das
in unserer tradition tragen wir nichts
auf dem rücken oder auf den schultern
wenn die kleinen sind dann machen wir
das alle aber wenn männer väter werden
dann hören wir damit auf warum ein vater
sollte nichts auf dem kopf tragen wenn
man die lasten wo anders als auf dem
kopf trägt tut der ganze körper weh und
außerdem sagt auch gott dass wir dinge
am besten auf dem kopf tragen
das leuchtet ein
wenn alle alles auf dem kopf tragen kann
es doch eigentlich nicht so schwer sein
ich probiere es aus gemüse frau mary
zeigt mir als erstes wie die ladung
geschichtet wird als nächstes das
geheimnis des publikums
[Musik]
etwa 20 kilo ganz leicht ich fang lieber
erstmal mit einer kleineren schüssel an
schichten
er hatte schon diese kleine wiese keine
chance ist ganz schön schwer für mich
die hände weg
[Applaus]
nächster versuch weniger gurken mehr
salat ist doch kein problem
das publikum scheint skeptisch aber dann
wie durch ein wunder
der hügel sattes grün glückliche kühe
hier ist die welt in ordnung hier im
derby clip für die schweiz oder wie wir
sind aber nicht in der schweiz
wir sind in der demokratischen republik
kongo und zwar in einer region die seit
jahren geprägtes von kriegen und
konflikten warum gibt gross gerechnet im
kongo schweizer kühe frag ich mich
gehört der käse
das sei ihre art des widerstand
widerstand gegen die rebellen sagt amir
safari denn die hügel hier wurden schon
oft überfallen
seit fast drei jahrzehnten kämpfen
rebellengruppen gegeneinander und gegen
die armee es geht um geld und um macht
weil es in den bergen gold diamanten und
alles mögliche wertvolle gibt während
der kämpfe seien ihre kühe oft getötet
oder geklaut worden sagte joseph marie
aber sie hätten dann immer wieder von
vorn angefangen wieder kühe gezüchtet
wie jobs geschaffen
die milch muss schnell in die käse
manufaktur transportaufkommen politisch
zugegeben das deutsche gesundheitsamt
ecke den ein oder anderen einwand doch
reinheit ist ja irgendwie auch
auslegungssache hier bedeutet reinheit
keine chemie sagt käser meister boni
fast nie chemie und rührt geheimnisvolle
pülverchen in die milch wir machen hier
gouda so wie es uns die belgischen
priester vor vielen jahren beigebracht
haben sie haben mir damals auch väter
camembert gemacht dafür haben wir jetzt
nicht mehr das werkzeug wir machen gouda
und zwar sehr guten sagt er und rührt
und schafft im regal stehen schon die
ausgereichten fertig für den versand 17
kilo produzieren sie haben tag und bild
für das ganze land sei das sehr gefragt
im kongo und seiner sei ganz besonders
köstlich in unserem gau da steckt viel
lieber ich habe eine arbeit und kann
meine familie ernähren so wie die
anderen vier auch das bedeutet uns sehr
viel
deshalb will ich mein wissen auch immer
weiter gewesen damit uns diese arbeit
erhalten bleibt und dann darf ich
endlich probieren ja eher ein sehr
milder gouda etwas weicher in der
konsistenz wie soll ich sagen
friedlicher käse ganz machte
[Musik]
mein markt in madagaskar obmann
entenbraten etwas vegetarisches oder
eine fischsuppe zubereiten möchte hier
gibt es alles was einen hort was ein
hobbykoch auch jede menge zwiebeln denn
die braucht man schließlich für die
meisten rezepte das normalste von der
welt zwiebeln auf dem markt kaufen um
sie zum kochen zu verwenden
hier in madagaskar gibt es allerdings
orte wo zwiebeln verboten sind
in dem dorf anton brunner zum beispiel
im zwiebeln tabu zusammen mit meinem
körbchen mache ich mich auf den weg um
herauszufinden was so schlimm an
zwiebeln sein soll
miss you daniel ein traditioneller
heiler weiß mehr darüber
auch er ist keine zwiebeln dass ich sie
mitbringen scheint aber in ordnung zu
sein
zwiebeln haben wir früher als waffe
gegen böse geister und unsere feinde
verwendet deswegen sind sie noch heute
verboten denn wenn man ihn ist dann
haben feinde es leicht einen zu besiegen
sie schwächen unser immunsystem
knoblauch seien noch gefährlicher sagt
missio daniel mit der angebaut dann brot
hagel die ganze ernte zu vernichten
das ganze geht auf die zeit der
madegassischen könige zurück matthew
daniel will mir ihren alten palast
zeigen mit diesem stück holz schützt der
heiler sich vor der bösen wirkung von
zwiebeln
und damit mir kein unglück oben auf dem
berg geschieht muss ich mein körbchen
unterwegs abstellen an dieser heiligen
quelle müssen wir uns reinigen bevor wir
den palast besuchen seinem schutz
entfaltet das wasser erst mit dem stück
holz hier
wir sind zwar nicht schmutzig aber auf
dem markt haben sie leute getroffen die
zwiebeln angefasst haben und die haben
ihre kleidung berührt
ich muss aber nur die hände waschen
nicht die jacke ok jetzt wenig sorgen zu
sein
ich hatte aber dann meint matthew daniel
noch es sei durchaus von vorteil etwas
zu oft etwas zu offen
glücklicherweise habe ich vom frühstück
noch ein kleines muffin übrig in ganz
madagaskar gibt es solche tabus so
genannte fa diesmal ist ist siegen
fleisch mal rote regenschirme und oben
auf dem berg sind schuhe vermuten wer
ein vati verletzt dem droht unglück um
böse geister milde zu stimmen opfern die
madagassen an heiligen orten und der
schamane kann unheil und krankheit durch
zeremonien abwenden
eine junge frau braucht seine hilfe
obwohl sie sich an ihre persönlichen fa
dies hält
ich esse keinen spinat kein
schweinefleisch und keine zwiebeln einer
davon bin ich nämlich einmal auf einem
auge eine zeit lang blind geworden
mittagspause miss you daniel koch
natürlich ohne zwiebeln
ich kann ohne zwiebeln gut leben lecker
ist es trotzdem und mit den kleinen
auberginen hier kann man sogar husten
heilen ich wurde trotz des zwiebel
körbchen von unglück verschont aber
gegessen habe ich an diesem tag besser
mal keine zwiebeln heute mal erledigt
auf steine und erde
lecker ich bin süchtig danach
wenn schwangere frauen in kenia an
steiner denken läuft ihn regelrecht das
wasser im mund zusammen
die schwester im vorbereitungskurs aber
schimpft wenn ihr steine ist und denkt
dass ihr dabei mineralien zu euch nehmt
habt ihr euch getäuscht
ihr bekommt würmer um es doch lieber
gemüse wenn wir eisenmangel habt nein
das sei einfach nicht das gleiche es ist
wie mit dem rauchen es beruhigt mich
ohne ein bisschen vom stein komme ich
morgens nicht aus dem bett
ich könnte jetzt einen richtig großen
stein verdrücken
was bei uns die saure gurke ist es hier
halter stein gibt sogar ganz normal im
supermarkt hier lebt sie steine sogar
fein säuberlich verpackt und zwar in der
ersten abteilung direkt neben den
popcorn und hier steht sogar darauf dass
die twisted sind also gerüstet
wahrscheinlich schmecken die besonders
gut
inmitten einer bananenplantage werden
sie abgebaut die steine quasi bio bei
drei jahren etwa gibt es den steine
trend in kenia mit dem abbau verdient
schon doppelt so viel wie mit dem anbau
von bananen oder mais erzählt er mir und
so klug sein die steine nicht so schwer
das sind ja keine steine zum bauen das
sind es steine die somit nicht schlecht
meine frau ist die auch ich solle doch
auch mal probieren
die schmecken wird texte sagt john na
das kann ja nicht so schlimm sein
[Musik]
jetzt wochenlang gebiss schmeckt avant
sorgen soll ich mir aber keine machen
sie lägen nicht schwer im magen und
seine kinder seien alles prachtexemplare
so ist ich konnte mir keiner die frage
beantworten ob die steine jetzt ganz
ungesund sind oder gar nicht so schlimm
den kindern schneidet nicht zu schaden
ansonsten gilt auch in kenia
bei risiken und nebenwirkungen naja sie
wissen schon
in kenias hauptstadt nairobi
kauft man möbel am straßenrand
möbelhäuser sind hier was für spießer
und eine schier gigantische auswahl gibt
es von ihnen christoffers ich will
wissen warum lieben die kenianer
ausgerechnet das sofa so sehr liegt es
an den farben der form oder der guten
qualität
nein nein das muster sei genau perfekt
bezirzt ladenbesitzer mister michael
seine kurz so fasst die müssten
schließlich ordentlich was her machen
mein sofa sollte modern aussehen und in
deiner wohnung in nairobi reinpassen
wissen sie bei uns sind die wohnungen
nicht sehr geräumig und dem sollten
viele menschen darauf platz haben wir
sollen doch alle zusammen mal
probesitzen schlägt mit michael vor und
führt uns zu seinem sofa number one
washington heißt es hier sitzt ist
präsident es wird um den preis
gefeilscht
natürlich der kunde entscheidet sich am
ende doch lieber für dallas hinten im
islam michaels wellblech megastore
werden die sofas gebaut und gefüttert
sind sie mit schaumstoff naja mit
schaumstoff resten wir kleben die teile
alle zusammen sagt er und dann kommt es
ins sofa warum es wird nichts
verschwendet wird gehobelt genäht
gehämmert mit vollem körpereinsatz nagel
depot im mund es muss schnell gehen
die nachfrage ist riesig aber warum
ausgerechnet nach sofas fragen ich gehe
ja na kaufen eher ein sofa set als ein
bett geschlafen lieber auf dem boden und
haben dafür ein sofa das ist unsere
kultur ist es ist unsere art ist die
ganze familie zusammen zu bringen
und um der familie den nötigen respekt
zu zollen sein die so verschieden
prunkvoll das sofa als statussymbol
ich verstehe neben ansieht ist gerade
ein selbst fertig geworden und soll
gespart werden
in kenia stil das edle teil darf auf gar
keinen fall schmutzig werden durch die
tür passt es gerade so aber die neuen
besitzer strahlend vor stolz wir lieben
unsere sofas wegen des materials und das
design ist wer jetzt auf den geschmack
gekommen ist mister michael würde
bestimmt auch nach deutschland
[Musik]
kaum ein stäubchen adrett und
blitzsauber sind die straßen und
außerdem in ruandas hauptstadt kigali
ist selten so richtig viel verkehr aber
einmal im monat sind die straßen sogar
komplett leer
wie kommt das der letzte samstag im
monat kurz vor acht uhr morgens zwischen
noch ein paar menschen über die straßen
die geschäfte sind verrammelt nach acht
uhr geht nichts mehr
sonst droht ein knöllchen denn heute ist
in uganda frei übersetzt heißt das
gemeinschaftlicher care tag staatlich
verordnet für alle ruanda im ganzen land
[Musik]
alt und jung schippen hacken und säubern
was die ohnehin schon recht kosovo
umgebung noch so hergibt
[Musik]
in diesem viertel geht es heute den
vielen mücken nestern im hohen gras an
den kragen
eine maßnahme gegen malaria buganda ist
ein teil von ruandas vision 20 50 ich
wünsche mir dass unser land als paradies
bekannt wird klingt nach
regierungssprecher aber gute stimmung
ist tatsächlich vor allem uganda
teilnehmern spürbar
okay sie die variante mit schwingen und
dabei arbeiten das klingt noch nicht so
richtig hin wo mogán da gibt es in
ruanda schon seit der kolonialzeit
richtig ernst genommen wird das
kollektive schuften aber erst seit
präsident kagame nach dem blutigen
völkermord 1994 an die macht kam
das hier ist der beste weg gefunden in
der gesellschaft zu heilen
keiner soll sich allein gelassen fühlen
der andere braucht dem wird geholfen
manche arbeiten manche so haben sie so
haben auch einfach nur um ein
schwätzchen zu halten zu halten einmal
im monat bis das hat ist das reden und
seine saubere stadt zu haben
wir lassen uns wir lassen uns wissen
belehren wir tun das für uns für nie uns
nach zwei stunden zwei stunden und
klönen treffen sich alle an wohnlich
alle an wohnungen zu besprechen
die stimmung ist fröhlich wir helfen
einander sagt mir eine frau das sei doch
schließlich alles was es auf der welt
brauche
[Applaus]
[Musik]
nein